Happy New Year my 2018 be the year when
the libertarian political party finally
begins to make a real difference many of
us hoped last year's presidential race
would be the election where a
libertarian finally broke through but
that was not to be sorry to keep you
waiting if he didn't get close last
election with two candidates lots of
people hated what's the point the point
is John we did do well in 2016
Nick's our works the chairman of the
Libertarian Party but we tripled all
previous records in the 45 year history
of the Libertarian Party we've never had
that kind of support from the electorate
and that's great tripled to what four
percent about three and a half what's
the point if that's success really
success is a long-term thing it's a
process it's not a particular election
more and more people are seeing that
when you elect Republicans you don't get
this sort of small government they run
on if you elect Democrats you don't get
civil liberties you don't get any of the
standing up for the little guy that they
say that they're all about both parties
are fighting over the ability to take
your tax money and give it to their
corporate special interest friends and
they're winning somehow their message is
more compelling to more Americans but
we're growing and they're dying voter
registration identity with Republicans
and Democrats is dropping voter
registration identity with libertarians
is the only party that's growing in a
few years the libertarians will again
hold an open to everyone convention to
pick a nominee for the presidential race
will that winner do better than Gary
Johnson did a lot of libertarians say
it's Gary's fault he was too low-key he
sounded like he was stoned people aren't
perfect no one has the perfect
combination of credibility experience
purity of message he was the best
candidate the delegates could have
picked and we had the best success that
we've ever had libertarians might have
more success if libertarian candidates
were invited more of the TV debates the
parties fly
a lawsuit to try to force that to happen
the media tries to help the old party
politicians because it's simpler it's
simpler to run a story where it's just
Republicans and Democrats it's red and
blue it's team a and Team B it's more
complicated to say you know there are
more political options out there so they
try and make us look silly Gary Johnson
looks silly on MSNBC when he was
suddenly asked about Syria though he'd
been talking about domestic affairs and
I think the Republican Party has gotten
really extreme in that category what
would you do if you were elected about
Aleppo about Aleppo and what is a lap o
and he didn't know anything about where
Aleppo is he knew what Aleppo was
absolutely and this is a common trick in
courtrooms and and interviews everywhere
is you you hit someone with a gotcha
moment and you take advantage of their
confusion it's a dirty trick but people
pull it and that's what the media did
[Applause]
but now it's the new year another chance
to show Americans what libertarians
stand for the rights of the individual
the right to free speech the right to
keep and bear arms the limitations on
the powers of government Republicans and
Democrats try to keep you off the ballot
absolutely they do they pass laws
specifically against libertarians in my
home state of Arizona the Republicans
passed a law to increase our signature
requirements to get on the ballot by up
to thirty times what do you mean
specifically against libertarians they
can't do that the floor debate in the
legislature had Republican leaders
saying this is to stop libertarian
candidates from running against us we
could lose our races if they run against
us they hate competition and you're
gonna be on the ballot in all 50 states
that's the plan
they're already on the ballot in the
yellow states they're working in the
gray states gary johnson helped with
that he absolutely did he brought a
credibility to the party and a
popularity that we're building on now
but it's not about any particular
candidate that's the real difference
between the Libertarian Party and say
Ross Perot when Ross Perot gets tired of
running for office there's nothing there
anymore the Libertarian Party is
millions of America
who have come together and said we want
a right to live our life to pursue
happiness any way we choose as long as
we don't hurt other people and we don't
take their stuff and the two old
political parties that's not what
they're about they're about taking power
and controlling you
you